bonsoir général merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on avait un
emmanuel macron très critique envers
cette institution
que cherchent-ils selon vous oui bonsoir
et bien écoutez les problèmes avec le
conseil de sécurité sont pas nouveau ça
fait plusieurs années j'allais dire
dizaine d'années qu'on en parle
simplement dans les propos du président
français
il y a deux objets le premier le blocage
récent les braquages récents qui sont
dus essentiellement à l'utilisation du
veto de façon quasiment systématique en
particulier dans le cas de la crise en
syrie est le deuxième sujet c'est bien
sûr la place de l'europe qu'il souligne
parce que ça n'a pas un lien direct avec
le conseil de sécurité mais c'est un
contrepoids qu'il voit s'installer entre
le combat je voulais dire entre les deux
grands que sont les états unis et la
chine
comment est ce que tu vas passivité les
deux conseil de sécurité de l'onu
justement sur la crise du convive 19
puisque c'est de là que sont partis en
tout cas ses récentes critiques même si
celle d'at depuis longtemps comme vous
le soulignez et bien écoutez je crois
que le conseil de sécurité pour être
plus global à trois problèmes un
problème de représentativité un problème
de gouvernance et un problème d' usage
du veto qui fait partie de la
gouvernance et pour la question que vous
me posez c'est sur ces derniers points
que nous allons élaborer c'est à dire
que coville 19
il ya eu des velléités d'en traiter mais
en fait aucun des membres permanents n'a
voulu vraiment traité et donc
naturellement sanusi n'était pas sur la
table
je rappelle que la france a été à
l'origine d'une demande d'une réunion du
p5 l'éperlan longues files les cinq
membres permanents pour essayer de
débloquer le système et les autres
membres permanents n'ont pas souhaité
répondre à cette demande française qui
évidemment amène à une absence de
discussion complet sur cette partie qui
est la partie gouvernance et usages de
du droit de veto d'ailleurs le droit de
veto la france avait fait des
propositions en particulier en disant
qu'il ne pouvait pas être utilisée dans
le cas où il y aurait un danger pour
l'humanité
une utilisation tout à fait
disproportionné de la force et personne
n'a retenu ces propositions finalement
j'en ai 25 ans qu aurait pu faire l'onu
en l'espèce dans cette crise sanitaire
est ce que la situe souvent vers une
marge de manoeuvre significative pour
tenter d'améliorer la situation était
différente aussi en fonction des pays
évidemment oui alors il faut élargir là
aussi le cercle de l'onu s'est pas
seulement le conseil de sécurité ni
l'assemblée générale et dans le cas du
cobp 19 c'est bien sûr l'om s et comme
vous le savez les etats-unis ont décidé
de se retirer de l'eau oms qui est pas
une façon très futés j'allais dire de
travailler avec un organisme
international en étant à l'extérieur où
on a plus d' influence sur ce cet
organisme et il aurait fallu bien sûr
que l' oms et le poids des etats-unis
comme d autres pays pour pouvoir avoir
un objet de gouvernance dans cette dans
cette crise qu aurait pu faire d'autres
l'om est ce parce qu'on sait qu'elle a
été extrêmement critique et dans la
gestion de la crise vous l'avez dit les
etats unis qui ont claqué la porte
critiquant notamment l' oms d'être à la
botte des chinois à ce que l'image va
être abîmée à la sortie de cette crise
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
alors le premier point c'est qu'il faut
souligner que monsieur joe biden le
président élu qui va être annoncé
j'espère très bientôt a décidé de
rejoindre l'om est ce qui me paraît une
mesure très sage l'om est évidemment été
critiqué parce qu'elle a mis un peu de
temps avant de dire que c'était une
pandémie et
le directeur général de l'om est ce qui
est un étui aupérin a été accusé par les
états unis d'être à la botte des chinois
qui avait retardé aussi bien sur la
déclaration de pandémie
donc il est probable que il elle aurait
dû réagir plus vite et simplement il
faut peut-être réforme est incertain de
choses à la terre de l'eau et mesk mais
c'est en étant à l'intérieur qu'on peut
le souligner au début de notre
discussion nous parlions des difficultés
de l'onu je voudrais simplement rappeler
rappeler une intervention du président
macky sall sénégalais au forum pour la
paix la semaine dernière qui a parlé lui
de la représentativité et ça on sait que
c'est un problème majeur la
représentativité au sein du conseil de
sécurité
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur les bases de
ce qui existait en 1945
naturellement l'afrique n'est pas
représenté au niveau des membres
permanents l'asie souhaiterait une plus
représenté mais le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui sur les continents ils
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
et donc là aussi la réforme du conseil
de sécurité bloqué merci dominique train
quand son chef de la mission militaire
française à l'onu d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur ft francs